millions of people in texas who endured
massive power cuts are now facing
critical shortages of
drinking water it's another day of
bitter cold it means more burst pipes
and flooded homes
while many remain without power for a
fifth day in a row think about that for
a second and nearly 12 million texas
residents are facing disruptions
to their water service in part due to
problems at the treatment plants
texas power officials say on sunday
night they were just seconds or minutes
away from the entire collapse of the
energy grid
which potentially would have left
millions of people in dark for months
omar villafranca is in dallas with more
on this story omar it is such a mess
it's still being investigated
what are issues that people are still
dealing with today five days later
well one of the things that you
mentioned that's good people are
starting to get their power back on but
now the lights are on this is what
they're having to deal with take a look
at this apartment complex a water pipe
burst
and just cascaded down into these
apartments
it looks like a frozen waterfall all the
things that were inside these belongings
they're ruined people are having to
throw them away that's going to be a
costly tab to recover
another thing that may surprise you
people are going to be dealing with
a surprisingly high electric bill
we walked in and about two-thirds of the
ceiling was collapsed there was sheet
rock all over the floor and water was
just
gushing in joel burns didn't have power
but he had flowing water in all the
wrong places
it's disheartening this week burns says
he reached out to
14 different restoration companies for
help with repairs
like busted pipes and damaged drywall
all 14 companies
declined because they were not available
or the job
was too big do you think that your
insurance company is going to be able to
treat you one of probably a million
other cases
i think ultimately yes but it's not
going to be fast we're going to be
dealing with this for
probably over a year and insurance will
not cover
everything it'll cost us thousands i
mean already we've just in the you know
supplies and stuff to clean this up
we're in the many hundreds governor greg
abbott has asked president biden to
declare
a major disaster declaration if granted
this will give texans the ability to
apply for individual assistance
from fema that individual assistance
will assist them
with funding to restore damage to their
homes
but repairs aren't the only financial
burden texans are now facing
are you worried about what your next
electric bill is going to look like
i'm happy because our rates locked in
but the nature of deregulation is some
people have fluctuating rates and
theirs are going to go up most residents
enter into
one of two types of contracts with
energy providers
a higher fixed rate or variable variable
meaning customers take the chance
and can pay low rates when demand is low
and higher rates when demand rises
houston resident megan o'neil paid over
two thousand dollars
in two days her february bill is now
more than three
thousand dollars it's like okay do i
feed my family
or do i run the heat which one do i do
joshua rhodes an energy expert at the
university of texas
explains that those with fixed rates
could also pay more in the future
that effect will take later as you know
utilities and
like assess you know how much money that
they need to recoup
eventually the customer always pays you
know kind of at the end of this
the mayors of houston and dallas know
this is going to be costly and they're
already raising money for a fund to help
residents
with those repair bills but cities are
also going to have monster
repair bills take this stat into into
consideration
in the city of dallas alone they're
going to have to repair 250
water mains that burst during the freeze
anthony
omar thank you